alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
asseyez-vous s'il vous plaît
asseyez-vous s'il vous plaît,
donnez-moi votre pied,
les gars, je suis tellement excité que c'est
le week-end des oscars et il y a tellement de
films incroyables nominés et tant d'
artistes merveilleux vont être célébrés ce
week-end et j'ai hâte de regarder mais je
pensais juste que l'une des
choses les plus importantes à propos des oscars est que
si vous gagnez un oscar, vous devez faire un
discours, donc j'étais juste curieux de savoir si vous gagniez
un oscar que diriez-vous
alors
ouais
cassie  a décidé de se réveiller à 4 heures du
matin ce matin-là pour se préparer pour l'école,
elle avait besoin de se vider la tête
et pendant ces trois heures qu'elle a passées à
se préparer,
elle n'a pensé qu'à une chose
étrangère
kfc